these are my party-planning
pulled off an amazing 80s party last
year off the hook
well uh for decorations maybe we could
stupid forget it what
oh i was just gonna say maybe we could
have streamers but that's dumb everybody
has streamers
never mind no yeah i think that's a good
idea what color do you guys think
well there's green
blue
yellow
red how about green
i think green is kind of
is there anything we're missing phyllis
you got the lights yes i got those cute
little ones
do you think i should have gotten the
big ones we'll see
angela drafted me into the party
planning committee her memo said that we
need to prepare for every possible
disaster
which to me seems
excessive
one two three
[Music]
ryan king of the party committee oh no i
really did not do it
no false modesty my friend phyllis i
need you to pick up green streamers at
lunch
i thought you said green was
no orange is
um so i had a couple of ideas to make
the stanford people feel more at home
each year we have a christmas raffle
it would never work here
okay
um another idea was karaoke
no a christmas drinking game yes god
help you
what
these are all terrible ideas and none of
them are on the theme of a nutcracker
christmas
i think you should leave
you're kidding
you tried this out it's clearly not for
you
it's time to go
come on
please thank you
okay thank you very much
this should have been up yesterday we
are right
what is that
the committee to plan parties invites
you to a margarita karaoke christmas
there's no such thing as the committee
to plan parties there is now we just
started it well you can't just start a
committee you have to have funding
what's your funding 200
what's ours again um 201. right
hey a margarita karaoke christmas party
that sounds like fun no that is not a
party there's only one party and it's
hosted by the party planning committee
and it starts at three o'clock then why
are there two flyers i understand that
this is confusing for everyone let me
explain
there's a party that starts at three
right and then there's a way more fun
party that starts at 2 45.
right and if you're interested in the
way more fun party all the info can be
found here on our more brightly colored
flyer
i didn't see where it was
dwight
you won the raffle no way
do you like it walkie-talkies
yes
well the committee to plan parties has
served its purpose
we're gonna disband in the name of
christmas
in the name of nutcracker christmas
oscar
i have a question
would you like to join the party
planning committee the committee with
all the women
yeah because i'm gay
no
certain events have transpired
and i've thought about certain things
and i'm sorry for the way those certain
events transpired
and i would just like to make some
changes about certain things
and certain situations in certain
accounts all right i'll join i'd love to
that's
thank you
thank you thank you
can i join too
never
this is the first christmas party i'm
throwing as head of the party planning
committee the theme is night in morocco
this isn't your grandmother's christmas
party
unless of course she's from morocco in
which case it's very accurate hey
phyllis
do i need this invite to get into the
party yes awesome i think this is going
to be
the best christmas party ever
angela
you're gonna move this for the party
right it's not on theme
it's the nativity scene
all right
okay keep your camel
sheep
elephant and the north african king can
stay everything else
goes in the drawer
i am not going to judge phyllis for
desecrating christmas
there is one person who will though and
phyllis just stuffed him into a drawer i
need you to get rid of the tree but
thank you
oh i don't think it's blackmail
angela just does what i ask her to do so
i won't tell everyone that she's
cheating on andy with dwight
i think for it to be blackmail it would
have to be a formal letter
i need you to put the christmas tree
back up
it's outside i didn't ask you where it
was i told you where it needs to be
shut up
excuse me
i'm not moving the tree face it the only
power you have over me is this little
secret that i know you're not gonna tell
oh and you want to know how i know that
because then you won't be able to play
on your stupid tacky parties anymore so
you move the tree
okay
angela's having sex with dwight
i caught them doing it after toby's
going away party
well don't look so surprised hey kelly
screw you
excuse me there's no way to address the
superior oh yeah screw you
too whoa
what was that all about you forgot her
birthday
it was yesterday
go ahead you do it
okay i insist
basically after phil's blackmailed
angela michael asked them both to step
down from the party planning committee
because there was too much drama what he
said was easy there
was a problem with having one head of
the party planning committee she becomes
too powerful so he appointed two heads
party planner
literally the stupidest humiliating
that's
on my side
so this is fun
my birthday was yesterday and everybody
forgot i got really dressed up and
excited and no one said a word there
wasn't even a party i think sometimes
people are really mean to the hot
popular girl
are you kidding
well i'm not done yet
dwight
this fits in the palm of my hand
you haven't blown them up enough
why have you chosen brown and gray
balloons they match the carpet what is
that
it is your birthday period statement of
fact not even an exclamation point this
is more professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer i can't
believe how bad this looks
are you trying to hurt my feelings
because if so you are succeeding
fortunately my feelings regenerate at
twice the speed of a normal lens okay
good then have you collected the money
from everyone i am working on it how
much do you have
six dollars
that's how much you and i contributed
damn it jim
i said i was working out
what exactly is the ppc
oh that's the party planning committee
they spend hours planning parties
excuse me guys
what's going on party planning committee
not your concern charles this doesn't
seem like a good way to spend company
time really
well then how would we come up with
great ideas like gyms go ahead no i'd
like to get back to work what you guys
jim
what is a two-way petting zoo
you bet the animals they pay you back
it's a great idea and we have a cake in
the shape of a veil of hay it's really
just a regular shaped cake but it's cool
and it's this isn't a good use of
company time michael whoa you're talking
about my anniversary party so okay
everyone except for michael go back to
your desk yeah why don't you do that
yeah here we go okay
okay
okay michael
i'm dissolving this committee what i
can't believe he's making us throw a
party for her i know right she's always
late she's always rude kind of makes me
want to throw a really bad party yeah
on purpose
phyllis
we should do it right here in the break
room
art or carrot cake
[Music]
[Laughter]
you